that's the best part of the meeting for
me I do enjoy enjoy that
so welcome to this morning's overview
and scrutiny committee
I've had a musical accompaniment as well
um welcome to this morning's overview
and scrutiny Committee of Stratford
District Council my name is Andy
Crumpler we'll be sharing today's
meeting
um I don't think we're too many fire
alarms today so if you do um
here the alarm will make our way out
um follow me because even though I've
got a bad hip when it comes to fires I
can run really quickly so make sure we
get out safe and well
[Music]
um
Obviously good to see that we've got the
Press here today and we're being
screened Live on YouTube
um I think that's probably going to be
YouTube's one of the highest audiences
participation so far this today
um so good to see everybody and again
just make sure that it is been
you'll be out in the world wide web so
people will will see you laughing at my
puns as the meeting goes on
right
first item on the agenda is apologies
any emojis please good morning Jay yes
we have three apologies from councilor
Rolf councilor Johnston and councilor
Keithley
brilliant thank you very much
um item number two is describe of
Interest
any disclosures of Interest
no brilliant
right we'll move on to the previous
meetings I will just make a little
statement here
um obviously we've got lots of new
councilors on the uh the committee many
of weren't in attendance at the previous
meetings obviously
um but as part of the Constitution you
are still allowed to vote on the
accuracy of the mean of those minutes
um it's in the in the Constitution it
was discussed that at previous minutes
meetings as well
first reasons for it but one of the main
reasons is that if only the people at
the meeting were able to vote and they
didn't turn up
um it wouldn't be core to vote on that
so makes sense if you want to do some
homework yourselves
um and speak to the people who are
actually at the meeting to see flower
fire and reasonable that would that
would be okay but don't feel that you
can't vote on these minutes so
um just to let everybody know that it's
it's okay to do so so
um we'll we'll look at the minutes are
the meetings Howard on the 31st of March
and the 14th of April
um obviously there's quite a bit and as
you can see we we did have walks of
police and the police and crime
commissioner in and we've had several
pages of uh issues on there Council
Frankie please
thank you chair yes I have worked out
that you and I are the only ones that
were at these meetings
um
I I'm happy to
to confirm the minute but when I was
reading the minutes there are quite a
number of items in there
um which I think need to be put on a
future
um on the on the future agendas that we
have on this
and they're not actually in the the work
program which is in item five oh the
good news is Council of tragedy we can
be flexible with our work program yeah
um and yeah it's it's some Fair points
there was lots of information the more
information get more quick answer
questions it raises so yeah I'm more
than happy
um for the work plan to be and it's an
ongoing work program we can adjust
things we don't have to adjust them
right now but by the next meeting we can
have a whole list of different items
that we want to adjust so I think my
plea was for
how to have a look at some of those
issues and put them on the work work
plan and I think also I'm not talking
about item four yet but the probably
some in there that need to go on the
work plan yeah and I think again prior
to the meeting we're talking about
um paperless weren't we so whether that
could be something to LinkedIn with a
climate change plan and a panel as well
so yeah so are you happy to propose them
yes I'll be happy to second number
because we were the yes this one's there
and uh members can we have a vote on
this happy to approve those
brilliant thank you very much
um we will then
um
I'm proposing we have a change of order
we know we'll now go on to item number
seven which is the update from from
bromford
are you happy with that
yeah that's fine um
yeah
Kevin so we have Kevin Bennett director
of localities and custom contact and
Brantford Housing Association and he's
going to give a presentation and then
listen to our questions some of which
have been presupplied and we'll all go
away small enough all the answers and
Kevin will have solved everything for us
as well so Kevin if you'd like to far
away please
uh yeah thank you chair so uh firstly um
thank you chair for inviting me along
and also for the committee for having me
along so I'll just um share the
presentation uh with the committee
so hopefully
Okay so we've navigated that that first
bit which is always good
um so what I've put together in the time
slot is
um a number of slides that I'm going to
go over fairly swiftly for the first few
which provide an overview of just uh
some some of the key themes around
bromford and then go into some of the
performance questions that have been
asked um and uh so I'm conscious I don't
want to kind of do Death by PowerPoint
but hopefully it gives you a flavor of
where things are and cover some of the
topics I did want to have some of my
wider team here today but unfortunately
many of them are off on annual leave
looking after kids as well so
um so it's just me and so I'll kind of
progress if that's okay chair
um so just a little bit about bromford
so uh in terms of uh who we are so we're
situated across the West Midlands and
and Southwest of England predominantly
as a social hiding housing provider
we've got around 44 000 homes
um and uh one of our key kind of
purposes is to invest in homes and
relationships particularly so that our
customers and communities can Thrive and
one of the key kind of areas that we
focus on is our neighborhood coaching
model which I'll go into a little bit in
terms of an overview but essentially
that's a provision of Frontline resource
across all of our communities that
support our customers who need it the
most to be able to thrive in their
community so it's a real kind of focus
of my team and that's around 250 College
out in the communities every day working
across communities including here
some of our organizational aims are
absolutely about building strength and
relationships with all of our customers
and typically when we look at bromford
we have a patch size of around about
193 residents to one neighborhood coach
who's also got the provision of an
income management advisor as well for
specialist financial support when you
look at perhaps a more traditional
housing provider that could be one to a
thousand residential customers in the
community we're very focused on making
sure that we try to understand our
communities as best as possible that we
understand the assets across our
communities that we really know where we
can support our customers to connect
with some of their their challenges and
that we fundamentally link things up
across communities so that we build
connections and with a view that we want
to enable and Empower our customers
through agency to be able to do things
for themselves as much as possible and
whilst we have many customers that do
you know live an absolutely normal life
there are some customers that need some
of our support more than others and our
focus is to help them to get that
support through our neighborhood
coaching approach and through connecting
connecting in the communities
and just a brief overview of the team
um so geographically you can see kind of
where we are but in terms of our kind of
setup we have a roughly uh kind of four
operating hours if you like that we
split out
um and it just shows the number of homes
that we've got across those areas and
also the neighborhood coaches that work
across those communities in terms of
that commitment through our through our
approach and my team in particular
covers a number of areas but
particularly our neighborhood coaching
approaches is key to supporting our
customers and communities to thrive
specifically to Stratford and the
district and this is how things look on
a more local level so one of the key
questions from the committee was you
know how do we split social rent and
affordable rent and shared ownership and
these are just some examples of some of
the numbers in areas across the district
where we've got Homes at bromford
support and the breakdown of those homes
in terms of Social and affordable and
shared ownership and so it just gives
you an idea of of the homes that we've
got across the district and we do have
some areas where we are looking and to
develop further as well in terms of
homes that we're building
and I thought it is also important to
just give an idea of and what does
social and affordable mean in terms of
against a private rental sector so first
and foremost
um last year Bromfield built um the most
social homes in the sector so 1265 which
we're really really proud of against a
difficult operating environment and
typically when we're talking about
social rent and affordable rent the
difference is you know around about 1400
pounds a year for customers but
typically social rent is 50 lesson
Market rent and affordable rent is 80 of
local uh Market rent so it just gives an
idea of of how customers particularly in
Social rent are supported uh through you
know the homes that we we provide
I wanted to touch briefly on the
operating environment and then
performance and hopefully address some
of the questions from the committee
through the slides
um
across the last year you know we all
know it's been uh particularly
challenging for customers and for
organizations inflation and cost of
living from two different lenses have
been very difficult and we absolutely
know from our perspective how difficult
customers have found the cost of living
and through our neighborhood coaching
approach particularly we've been able to
support directly those customers through
a number of ways to make sure that you
know we understand our most vulnerable
in communities and we put things in
place to support them but also generally
organizations have have you know really
struggled in terms of things like
resources and you know that the cost of
of delivering businesses and so when we
talk about the 1265 homes that we built
last year it's something that that we're
particularly proud of the labor market
is really difficult at the moment in
terms of um you know Recruitment and
resources from a bromford perspective
what that means to us is it's absolutely
Paramount to make sure that we hold on
to our people and and that we recognize
our talent and as a great places to work
accredited organization that's something
that we're really Keen to do and I think
particularly for the committee the
regulatory changes in the housing sector
over the last few years since the tragic
instances of grenfell have been
significant and those things cover
Building Safety they cover fire safety
they cover health and safety and
particularly things like tenant
satisfaction measures and engagement
that have been born out of the white
paper I mean as an organization we
absolutely need to respond to those
challenges and make sure that the
services that we deliver are as good as
they can be I think most recently what's
been pressing is the tragic death of
ishab in Rochdale through condensation
damper mold issues that's something that
has really brought the sector into a
place where we really need to make sure
that what we do addresses the need of
our customers in our communities
uh from a bromford perspective over the
last Financial year it's been
particularly challenging as well for two
reasons one positive change in terms of
we are bringing together a significant
transformation program so this is
bringing multiple systems through our
Legacy organizations into one which make
things easier for us to operate but also
that means we can make things easy for
our customers as much as possible and
then unfortunately last year we suffered
a significant Cyber attack in July and
so in the last Financial year that's
been um you know a significant event and
you know for a number of weeks we were
working on WhatsApp pen and paper which
was very very challenging and I know
that that was challenging for our
customers as well so that was
particularly um difficult in terms of
the last Financial year in terms of some
context but
um in terms of our performance and these
are some of the slides that I think the
committee wanted to kind of get on to
from a contact center perspective there
are a number of things here so first and
foremost
um as as the leader of that contact
center service uh we want our services
to be inclusive and we want them to be
Broad and so we don't just talk about
answering the phones we talk about web
chat we talk about how we have a digital
kind of offer we talk about how
customers can register
um uh their needs on the customer portal
and our digital and voice split is is
starting to change so we are getting
more customers that are saying actually
we'd like to use digital but in
inclusive Manner and particularly for
our vulnerable customers and
neighborhood coaching approach from a
Frontline perspective is absolutely key
so we really press home that the way
that customers can contact us at
bromford through multiple Channels with
the neighborhood coaching approach
directly in communities being the leader
of that in terms of the contact types as
you'd expect as a housing provider the
biggest driver of contact is around our
repair service and you know it's our
biggest transactional service and we
don't always get it right so we know
that we've got a number of kind of
things that we're working on to make it
as good as it can be
um and across the last year particularly
towards the end of last year
um in terms of contact center
performance answering the phones for
example we didn't do as well as we
wanted so through some issues with
systems that we had post cyber that
causes some real challenges but we
started to bring that performance back
now and we're delivering around about an
average speed of answer of four minutes
or under and we answer roughly between
93 and 95 of our calls for customers
which is uh positive and getting better
from a repairs perspective we know that
this is a really significant part of
discussion across housing and we are
really Keen that we're transparent about
where we are with this so we absolutely
know that we need to continue to do
everything we can to understand uh our
repair service we have roughly 8 000
repairs that we have at any one point in
our Whip and we want to bring that down
further so that we can increase the
speed of repair and we'd like to get
that into a 30-day kind of completion
cycle
um we absolutely commit additional
resources into our service as much as
possible and we absolutely know that
things like compliance and safety are
key so across April for example you can
see some of the numbers there as a
committee so gas installs 106.
electrical and gas completions shown as
1 200 and 559 so that's where we're
going and doing safety inspections and
you can see that we're reducing our kind
of work in progress pots are both across
both of those to make sure that our
response times can improve in terms of
components that we replace so this is
where we need to do things like
replacing components in kitchens or full
kitchens and bathrooms doors windows or
roofs just in the last month we've
invested over 500 000 in those those
programs and um overall um for this
particular part of of the bromford
service our customers have scored us as
81 in terms of customer satisfaction
um slightly more specific to the
district so we have 897 live repairs
across the district that we are working
on from an emergency response
perspective we've had no breaches in
terms of that respond on response on
same day or next day repairs
again specifically in Syria 90.5 percent
of our customers would recommend our
repair service to a friend and I say
that knowing that we still have things
to do across our repair service where we
know that we don't get things right and
in terms of our re-let service 100 of
our customers would recommend our re-let
service to a friend as well so that's
where we are you know making sure that
that first interaction with with
bromford that we try to do things as
good as we can
one of the key areas of focus
particularly for the regulator and the
Ombudsman across the sector is across
complaints and this is where this really
comes to the Forefront and at bromford
we've um kind of made some changes in
our approach to our team in terms of
investing in resources and making sure
that we've got a standalone impartial
setup to deal with complaints and
typically across the year we've got a
run rate each month of anywhere between
170 and 300 complaints depending on the
time of the year and seasonality as well
and overall in the last Financial year
we had less complaints than a previous
Financial year but what I would say is
that that the peaks of those complaints
at times really put pressure on our
operational Services because we had big
spikes depending on where things were
particularly around condensation dampen
mold and how that meant our customers
interacted with us but we do have a
significant focus on complaints we had
an enormous amount of complaints that
come in around the Christmas period and
we've reduced those and and responder
says and resolve them by about 500 less
which is really really positive we've
got a really good close relationship
with the housing Ombudsman
um and we know that that's a key to make
sure that we follow the code of conduct
against the housing Ombudsman that's
been set out and most importantly we
feel that transparency and inclusion is
uh absolutely front and foremost with
complaints so we have particularly with
our stage two complaints we have what we
call our linen ctin which are
essentially our own scrutiny panels of
customers that support us with
complaints resolution impartially and
that's really important to us to have
that lived experience lens from
customers
the one thing that's really come through
from complaints is the amount of
condensation damp and mold issues that
we've had as a whole sector and bronford
moved at Christmas to have a fully
resourced and dedicated team that
specifically deals with condensation
dampen mold Standalone so that we
address that really robustly as an
organization
and then in terms of the bottom
left-hand side of this particular slide
what you can see is some of the
day-to-day kind of themes that we have
so again as you'd expect many around our
repair service condensation dampen mold
and also some from a rent perspective as
well just in terms of the breakdown
from an overarching customer experience
perspective this just shows um the kind
of exact summary as we went turn the
financial year in terms of our
satisfaction across the whole
organization so 85.4 percent
um uh customers saying they were
satisfied and would recommend us and a
year-to-date of 82.7 so from our
perspective
um we feel that that's a good uh score
but actually we want that to be better
and we set ourselves an 85 to 90 Target
and at the moment in month for last
month rather we achieved 89 so that's
really positive for us and we we
complete about a thousand surveys for
customers every month and you know
between seven and ten thousand surveys
for customers across the 12-month
rolling profile so that we've got a
really good statistical representation
of data
one of the key themes of the white paper
was about engagement and listening to
customers so we measure that too we ask
our customers do we say that we do what
we said we do in terms of our listening
act and 67.5 of customers say that that
generally we do and what that says to me
is that we've got some room for
improvement um to make sure that we take
on board those customer comments and
again in terms of overall customer
satisfaction making sure that our
services are easy to use is really
important for colleagues and customers
and 80 of our customers tell us that
they think that they are easy to use
there's a big gap in the middle of those
two graphs of data and that's where we
had a Cyber attack and we couldn't
measure anything because we couldn't
access our systems so that's the reason
for those gaps
from health safety and regulation
perspective
um being a social landlord is absolutely
a Paramount that we get health and
safety right across all measures across
the last year we had a an Ida which is
an in-depth audit from the regulator and
we achieved and sustained a governance
one and a viability one rating which are
the two top grades that you can get from
the regulator that say we've got strong
governance across the organization and
transparency and that our viability as a
provider is is strong as well
we achieved all of our
um uh regulatory uh sorry our
operational safety metrics and these are
mainly around gas and electricity
um uh checks and installs and from a
wider more strategic lens
um we had no breaches around HSE
measures for example so we achieved our
health and safety obligations across
those three areas
one of the things that the committee
asked was about anti-social behavior and
and our approach to antisocial Behavior
which I think for communities and
customers is very challenging it is a
really challenging area as a social
housing provider to be able to support
customers in those circumstances our
neighborhood coaching approach is key to
that having those really good
relationships with customers and being
available for customers
um you know in a small community-based
way as I said earlier with an average of
about 193 customers per neighborhood
coach that means that we really get to
know our communities and those people
that live in our communities and so
that's the first way that we really
support customers customers with
anti-social Behavior secondly we have a
specialist dedicated Community safety
team who then deal with more complex
cases or legal cases where we need to
support
complainants or perpetrators for example
in different ways and potentially take
action to resolve those things or make
sure that have got the right mediation
in place
so across the district particularly for
the committee at a more local level we
had 22 customers that made complaints
around ASB and we had 20 perpetrators
that we were working with to try and
resolve matters and the majority of
these cases were around and noise
nuisance which is one of the most common
topics across antisocial behavior and
we've had no kind of formal proceedings
at this point against any of those those
customers
just the final couple of slides now so
um homelessness is a huge topic for us
at bromford
um it's a huge topic for the sector the
demand for housing versus uh you know
the availability is is has got a gap and
so for us making sure that we do
everything we can to reduce homelessness
and and also avoid putting pressure on
on our local Authority Partners is key
um first of all we look to make sure
that we take all of the action that we
can through our neighborhood coaching
approach to avoid any kind of eviction
or abandonment action whereby actually
we're saying to our customers it's no
longer sustainable for you to live in
our home and that's something that we
absolutely try to make sure that that is
is key uh for us so that we do
everything we can to have successful and
sustained tenancies and then also we
make sure that we do everything we can
to increase our homes availability to
customers through basic things like
income and expenditure understanding
making sure we really under stand
customers needs that are applying for
Homes at bromford
so they're really key for us generally
across the sector you know organizations
through the statutory homelessness
household process left around 18 of
homes we've in the last couple of years
let 30 through that process at bromford
and building more homes for social rent
to enable our customers to thrive is
still high up on our agenda so that we
really do support our customers across
communities to get into affordable
housing and social rented housing
um so I was conscious of quite a few
slides there that's a Whistle Stop tour
and over to any questions and and thank
you yeah first imagine question
um Kevin thank you um we'll be able to
have a copy of those slides because lots
of detail in there
um and and some of them are quite small
but obviously because you're getting so
much information on so if if you could
let us have those that would be really
helpful and again
um
and it is pleasing to see that obviously
we sent you lots of questions in advance
and lots of them have been been tackled
um I know Council passing on was
concerned about the age of the housing
stock and the PC writing do you want to
come in on that Council passenger and
put your microphone on before you come
in please
um well just to clarify the first part
of your presentation did I when you
referred to
457 social houses
um is that in Stratford District yes so
so those um the breakdown of of numbers
across those two at that slide with the
two kind of uh boxes with a breakdown of
a local level of affordable and social
rent and also shared ownership as well
there was
457 social and 32 affordable and I
missed the shared yep
um let me have a quick look so the shed
was 149 and then Bishops itchington was
189 social rent uh six affordable and 35
shared ownership
right so yeah so
um yeah what what's the a um well what's
the age of your housing stock so it's
it's mixed um I haven't got a specific
age of of that but I can get get that
for you um but I would say is it's quite
mixed and obviously some of that will be
older but we do have new developments
across the district and pipeline
development too because you didn't take
over any of the old Stratford District
Council housing stuff did you so it's
all been built in the last 25 years
essentially most of it yet to the best
of my knowledge but I can I can
certainly take that away and make sure
that that's that's uh an accurate update
for you all right so so have you got
figures on the EPC ratings of your
no I couldn't get those that come in
really late yesterday unfortunately I
think so I couldn't get those but I can
send that to you and I'm fortunate a
colleague that I needed to get those
figures from uh in in the team isn't
isn't in this week so I know that's a
specific specific one from Howard that
came across and I couldn't get that at
that notice unfortunately so my
apologies but I can get that for you and
that's fine uh so so just as a quick
extra one then I know oh am I alive
oh all right well orbits are getting
um grants for their older housing stock
to bring them to to do a a retrofit are
any of your houses old enough to to
apply for that Grant uh so we first and
foremost we would make sure that we uh
adhere to a decent home standard
um so uh you know we look at all of our
homes to make sure that that we apply
that standard across we do get um grant
funding so we have a community
investment team that sits with me
um over the last three to four years
we've um kind of brought over a million
pounds a year of uh kind of Grant uh
funding through that scheme and we do
apply that into homes and communities uh
whether it's from swing parks to uh you
know kind of supporting food banks
um and we have committed in our new
strategy actually that that we will make
sure that our
older homes
um have got the same standards as our
new homes built so that's a significant
info you know investment in our new
strategy but fundamentally we we can get
different types of funding but we
challenge ourselves to make sure that
we've got a decent home standard that
applied across all of our homes for
customers and we do listen engage with
our customers in that process too so for
example one of the things that our
customers have really called out to us
is you know some homes don't have a
shower so we've made sure that we've
changed our decent home standard and and
the way that we then
work in homes that don't have a shower
to start putting showers in I know it's
a very specific example but actually
it's very specifically called out by our
customers so yes various different
Avenues to make sure that we bring
things up to standard
before I bring cancer while like Huggins
in
um there's a point that's just come out
there that I think it's going to be
beneficial for us as committee going on
the earlier we get the questions to the
people are coming in to speak to us the
better reply we'll get and obviously the
EPC was done last minute and it's we've
been inside of flux ourselves so since
the election so um I think you know
we'll give ourselves a little bit of
leeway on the first uh first one but if
we can get the questions into the people
coming in to speak to us the earlier the
better so we all get a better answer so
could you turn your microphone off
please cancel them and councilwalee
hoggins then Council Frankie please
hello
this is a link really with your you
mentioned the decent home standard
um we sent off time then she had a lot
of questions about repairs and hotlines
in order to sort of um expedite repairs
to properties
um can you talk us through please
um
the preventative measures that you put
in because
um being reactive is never an efficient
way to be
um and it is that
um you know preemptive Replacements I'm
thinking particularly for example older
storage heaters that are very
inefficient and really really expensive
for people to to to you know that that
is causing a lot they are causing a lot
of for your poverty so these really you
mentioned a little bit about how many
kitchens you'd replace that kind of
thing kitchens and bathrooms but but
that's really
what I'm wanting to drill down is how
are you identifying you know the
preemptive repairs and Replacements
please thank you so so we do have what
we call a home investment um program and
portfolio and that's again a dedicated
team uh counselor that
um uh completely focuses on the
replacement of uh you know key parts of
home so whether that's doors and windows
whether that's bathrooms and kitchens we
have a cyclical program that is
proactively looking at that and and
we're constantly looking at how we can
make sure we find a really clear balance
between uh you know the the lifetime of
a component that might be something that
you look at very cold from a one lens
but actually what's the importance of
making sure that that is replaced as
quickly as possible for a customer so
that when we're talking about customers
thriving in their homes that that's
really true so we have a dedicated
program that does that and we look to
make sure that that we replace things uh
even before their life cycle end where
customers need that additional support
and so that's that's hugely proactive
um from a a more operational repairs
perspective as well we
um have uh obviously a reactive service
but what we're moving to now is a
proactive service across what we do
around repairs so that we are not
waiting for that call to come in we're
not waiting for that customer to feel
like they've got an issue or that
nobody's talking to them so that we're
getting in homes uh quicker and then
again from a Frontline colleague
perspective our neighborhood coaching
approach is is hugely proactive so
unlike other organizations where you
know that ratio of colleagues to
Residents in communities is quite high
and typically some providers that might
be one to a thousand for us as I said
it's it's roughly one to 193 and that
varies at the point depending on the
complexities perhaps of the community or
or the type of community
um those colleagues uh work with
customers to help identify proactively
issues in homes too so particularly for
us connotation dampen mold has been a
really key focus and all of our
Frontline colleagues are trained to
understand
um you know the science to look for the
environmental science to to kind of be
thinking about any conditions in the
home and also we've started to install
sensors into our homes so that we
proactively for those customers that are
happy for them to be installed
understand some of those environmental
conditions for our own learning so that
we can then address any significant
issues of condensation damper mold as an
example so we definitely have a number
of things there not just reactive but
I'd say broadly that that overarching
program of component replacement and
then you know a proactive approach in
terms of service delivery and then our
neighborhood coaches who were really
well trained to understand
um you know conditions of homes and also
to report things for customers
particularly vulnerable customers who
need that extra support
this one one supplementary question I'm
not expecting you to have the answers
but if you could just come back with it
with the answers to this is that okay
it's particularly the storage heaters
um particularly for those residents in
villages tend to have storage heaters
and it is really
um how many properties in in the
Stratford District are heated using
storage heaters
on what is the average age of those
heaters and how many of those heaters
have been replaced
in the last
two years
please okay yeah that's fine thank you
thank you
so how would all kind of um direct that
to three
that's great
um
yeah they're touching I will bring you
in case if I actually haven't gotten you
honest
um yeah I think the more dampen
consolation issue is quite a theme
um obviously you've talked to talk to
them about the sensors which is which is
really positive
um what other initiatives have you
trying to do obviously
um
we saw about the poor young child who
died
um due to mold issues
um complications
um
apart from the investment in the census
what else are you invest into transform
that place
yeah so I think
um as you say chair that the census is
uh for us
um a proactive way of looking at
tackling these issues to understand
um home conditions and working with
customers to make sure that um we can
see things coming as opposed to reacting
so that's that's something that we've
started to trial and that's really
important and that's uh kind of being
ongoing for a number of months
um secondly is the investment that we've
made in a dedicated condensation damper
mold team from a a resourcing
perspective and also upskilling all of
our front line colleagues to make sure
that we've got regular contact with
customers that we know what we're
looking for in homes and therefore we
can tackle things uh quickly
um before uh you know any significant
conversation damper mold issues arise
and and we have also made a significant
kind of uh
in raid in terms of analysis around the
homes that we've got to understand the
types of homes that actually are more
susceptible to condensation dampen mold
issues so that we understand where to
target our energy and effort so through
those combined teams that's that's key
and then we start to look at any issues
that we find through that that
understanding intelligence and say do we
need to do something differently with
these homes does that need to urgently
go into a um a program of work to then
do something differently around heating
or around insulation for example so we
use that intelligence and and that
resource and those dedicated teams to
then inform some of that from an asset
perspective and a home perspective
so just to summarize then your key
methods are prevention where possible
um identification
prevention and better training so staff
can react more promptly to the issues
cancel Friday please
thank you chair
um
quote 22 ASB cases could you tell me
whether or not that includes drug
dealing
uh thank you councilor for the question
um I don't have that specific
um kind of breakdown uh
uh within those numbers that that's uh
as I said it's I suppose it says the
majority are noise nuisance but I could
look to find that detail
um I know broadly we do have uh you know
a number of um anti-social Behavior
cases where
um things like drugs uh substance and
alcohol misuse are um you know a key
topic um but I can find those numbers
for you and give you an idea of what
that looks like for that specific Focus
if that's okay
yeah oh again I think it's just on the
fact that we sent information like for
Kevin to look at that was one of the
issues was ASB drugs and
um cocoon and
um potentially you know modern day
slavery exploitation and vulnerable
vulnerable residents so I think
um a lesson learned then again if we
want the information it would be helpful
to get in advance
um what what I'm asking to know is what
obviously you work with different
partners so we could tell you you use on
on the partners you're working with on
ASB and regarding ASP what would you
want from us as a as a council to help
you improve the situation
um yeah thanks thanks uh for the
question chair I think
um you know broadly as an organization
uh the relationship that we've got with
our local Authority Partners is key so I
think having just a a regular you know
relationship
um where we can have regular touch
points to talk about some of the issues
that we we might be facing within within
the district is is always positive and
to open up those channels of
communication
um and to work in Partnership so you
know we work in a multi-agency
partnership with lots of different
organizations and I think just having
that that approach whereby we build upon
that relationship with yourself is
probably the first step
um and also talking about
um as you said Council fragile that you
know what are those issues and so that
we've got an understanding of the issues
in the district and and what we can
jointly do to combat those
um I'll soon to be
hugging the questions here so feel free
to jump in or if you think I'm asking
the right question so that's fine
um
obviously the customer satisfaction
Figures were really good there was one I
think about 67 and I think it was the
listening what
um I think
one do you Benchmark yourselves against
other rsls locally and two
um
one of my residents has come
biggest book Bears is to do with gdpr so
when certain questions are raised about
an issue particularly from with with
counselors interviewing interfering
intervening it might be an avoidance
that so I apologies as well
um
all of a sudden the contact center staff
quote gdpr and I sometimes think that is
a bit of an excuse to get away around
the answer in the question
um so it would be good to ensure that
staff are fully try and update to
some explanation to the the people
that's having um your staff or other
rsls I know you can't comment on those
uh about issues reporting repairs or or
or saying that the repair appointment is
not appropriate because the person's ill
Etc oh we can't do that anyway and the
people still turn up and they drag the
poor person out to bed because so that
is not acceptable so again just some
points around that would be interesting
please how how that's been tackled
trained and what advice you could give
them to counselors when they're
contacting yourselves to make sure they
get through to the right person first
time yeah okay thanks for the question
so in terms of our customer satisfaction
measures so I guess from a from a bronfu
perspective we have seen an improvement
in in our customer satisfaction measures
which is really positive
um however we don't take that lightly in
terms of that needs to be sustained and
with the introduction of the new tenant
satisfaction measures
um which have come into Force as of the
first of April this year which have come
from the white paper and the regulator
the transparency of benchmarking across
all kind of providers is going to be
there and and open for scrutiny as we
come towards at the end of this year
into the next financial Year and that
covers things like overall satisfaction
ASB
safety measures a range of factors I
think there's 22 tenant satisfaction
measures and that's going to be the
place where all providers are held to
account against their performance in the
first Consolidated way I think in the
sector really for a long time the way
that we start to work with our customers
from a listen and that perspective so
our engagement and
influence strategy is particularly built
around what we call our local influence
Network and our customer and Community
influence Network so they are customers
that represent our communities across
all of our operating areas that come
together and and talk through the
challenges that they have heard from
other customers in the community and
bring it to you know leadership teams
and forums at bromford so that we can
start to understand and Tackle those and
the way that we look at that more in
depth is we say what does all of our
customer data tell us where are we
getting things right and where are we
getting things wrong and also what do
our customers tell us through those
forums whereby we can then say we're
going to work with you in a co-design
manner to then make those changes where
customers most need them
and from a a gdpr and I guess escalation
perspective so all of our councilor
inquiries and MP inquiries come through
to local teams so that there's teams
with local knowledge of issues in
communities and also we try to build up
those local relationships with
councilors and MPS and we have a
specific set of targets to make sure
that we respond in time to all of those
so that's typically our normal route our
contact center teams for example um you
know are trained on things like gdpr as
standard so that's something that should
never be an issue and if it ever was and
I'd welcome that feedback absolutely and
so that's really important to us but yes
in terms of working with councilors MPS
in particular I mean that's something
that I pick up on a regular basis and I
really welcome you know an open kind of
conversation and level of Engagement
around that with my team
to carry on
um
so yeah a couple of things
um it's quite interesting well first of
all
um the neighborhood coach uh you touched
on my areas save them
um and obviously we have quite a few in
that area
um the name podcast is is really good
her name is Jody and yoga I have to give
you some positive feedback when I
emailed her the other day she emailed me
back within 15 minutes which I was
impressed I know that's probably going
to be an exception rather than at all
and yeah I didn't expect
her to get back in touch quickly so that
is a really positive feedback
um it would be interesting to see The
Benchmark in comparisons that come out
later in the air early next year to see
how rsoles red salvages social landlords
so I apologies for jargon there
um another learning point from me and
for the committee we'll make sure we
don't talk in jargon especially when
people listening online
um I think that is really positive so we
need to see about that and it would be
good to you know we'll have you back in
the year 18 months time to talk about
the issues so that is really positive
but
is your benchmark performance in terms
of customer satisfaction
um likes to be better because you or
your neighborhood coaches have less
customers to deal with do you think that
is like to be the issue
um so I think that's a really good
question and I'm glad that um Jody come
back to you with a good response I can
assure you that nobody's been prompted
about that at all
um uh so I do think that uh from a
bromford perspective the ratio of
Frontline colleagues that we see as an
investment
um for our customers and our communities
being lower absolutely contributes to
some of the satisfaction levels that
that we've got to at the moment
um I would say that our satisfaction
levels have not always been where they
are currently and we've had to do some
work around you know normal kind of
operational
um improvements to to support where we
are but if I think about
um you know my previous organization
that I was an executive director at as I
said um that was uh you know a ratio of
a neighborhood officer of one to eight
hundred to a thousand and was very
reactive whereas our approach is very
much based upon
um you know a proactive approach really
knowing customers needs more
personalized level and helping those
customers who need help the most to
connect in communities for them to you
know go back their businesses as an
everyday person so I do think that helps
thank you councilor Wiley hoggins
here um Miss Platts you may want to help
with this question as well but we have a
lot of new counselors in place on the
council at the moment and what would be
useful I think is a designated telephone
number perhaps for us to ring but also
to know who these neighborhood coaches
are where they're positioned who they
are and how we contact them for those
for that for those for those um for
those houses there because it was
something we discussed in a little a
little a little bit earlier that
um you are dealing with people that
don't have a lot of phone credits who
don't have landlines that they can use
you know and if they're waiting for four
minutes because on hold then that is
four minutes of potentially the credits
being used on their telephone so
actually sometimes it will come to a
counselor because we've got telephones
that we we can we can use and these
things need to be need to be factored in
so I think giving out the information
that we need is a is a pre in a preempt
away would be would actually be really
useful and knowing where the Romford
homes are within within our different
Wards because north south east and west
it is in is important that I would find
that very useful and it also circumvents
the gdpr business and I can't speak
about this because you know if the
council is ringing on a designated
telephone number then you know
that has to take some some priority does
all up make sense yeah I think it does
and certainly you know happy to have a
further conversation with you around
that and just explore that um certainly
from a customer perspective
um all of our customers absolutely
should know who their neighborhood
coaches are I know there are some
coaches and customers who perhaps
um don't have as much contact with some
of the coaches as others and those
numbers are on our website so you can
type in an area and then find a
neighborhood coach
um but I'm very happy to kind of work
with you further to provide you know a
more local view of who works where and
what their details and you know where
our homes are um so that it's really
really clear for you
here's actually what that would enable
if we knew who they were is that we can
establish relationships with with the
with the neighborhood coaches we can
have regular meetings perhaps if
required to
um to see to see what we can all be
doing to help those residents so that
we're being proactive rather than
reactive because sometimes you may have
information that we potentially need to
know so that we can you know support and
help in other ways thank you chair
I think that's that's very positive I
think
um I don't do any other further
questions
um I think that the presentation was
excellent and responded to
um what would asked and again once we
get there we can have a look in more
detail on it and why ask her raise a few
more questions so again if you could
leave contact details for uh for Mr
Alison then we can get back in touch so
thank you very much we will hopefully
you'll be coming back to us in about 12
18 months time and as very informative
so thank you very much I'll propose we
have a little break for a minute or two
whilst uh Mr Bennett sorts out his it
and disappears I'll need to stretch my
Elixir as well um so if we have a
proposal of a two minute break uh is
everybody help with that thank you
foreign
all right thank you for that slightly
longer than the two minutes but uh
there was lots of things to be sorted so
we'll now move on to
uh number five we've discussed the
minutes of previous meeting and the
Mexican requirement change panel
um the work plan I'm proposing we
slightly move this to the end of the
agenda because those are the things we
want to talk about particularly Tusk and
French group but I have noticed I've
noticed some of the points uh we've
discussed earlier on and on our note
councilor fragile racing issues
regarding from the previous minutes that
he wants to talk about on the work plan
so and I know he's been speaking to
Harry about those so we can talk about
that
so we are going to come back to number
five
um if that's okay
I don't send you Ascension so that's
good uh Chairman's brief nothing to
update at the moment again early into
into the committee cycle so there will
be updates as we go along
we'll now move on to automated agenda
which is the Tuscan finish group for
housing associations
um
and this is uh came about because the
notice of motions uh the Council on the
12th of December 2022 and we discussed
this as you'll see from the minutes of
the 31st of March 2023
um Mr post do you want to give a brief
outline of why we do test confidence
groups for new members if that would be
helpful please yes
um
right we're on yeah the Tuscan finish
groups are really a sort of chance to
get under the skin of an issue we use
them
um where sort of formal meetings have a
sort of value in scrutinizing things and
uncovering things the difference with
the task and finish group is it's a
smaller group of people it's perhaps a
slightly less confrontational sort of
situation than what we've seen this
morning and it's the chance for people
to sort of take things away and discuss
them do a deep dive into things
um the way I found that they work best
is if the um the broader committee give
a brief to the task and finish group and
then the task and finish group have got
a real chance to sort of take that issue
and sort of run with it we can give you
more supporters officers we can sort of
have more
of a less formal discussion with you
realize that the discussion is going to
different areas
um and sort of say give a deep dive into
matters that can be reported back to the
main committee so as we're not using the
whole committee's time in finding it and
it's it's quite an effective way of um
unpicking an issue and sort of taking
things forward is that useful
that's the rice yep
that's committee or is that just a
general term for these groups across the
council
and what is their composition
okay
um they tend to come from the open juice
over the instructor committee
um I suppose just by habits really as
much as anything there isn't a
particular reason why any committee
can't use a task and finish group
um so but they they have conventionally
sort of come from the open Distributing
Committee in terms of the composition of
the group that's really for the
overriding sort of panel to decide
um they tend to be sort of three or four
members and with the ones we've done in
the past I'm just thinking of the um the
self-built task competitors group is
quite a reasonable we did that there are
some were some members from this
committee and they chose to co-opt um a
couple of other members with expertise
in that area or particular interest in
that area sometimes you'll find that the
issues sort of overlaps and things you
might want some people with sort of
planning expertise or housing expertise
to join you and then as officers will
support that with whichever sort of
officers are
our best place to sort of give the
committee the advice that they need so
it's fairly flexible they can get a bit
unwieldy if they get more than sort of
about half a dozen members on them so
that they tend to be smaller grades but
really that's within within the gift of
the administration it's what you want to
put
really good question
um
we've had a couple last year one of
which was on the the reasons behind the
the breakup of the partnership between
Warwickshire County science traffic
District Council uh and that came up
with lots of different
um points that were agreed by work
District Council as well and it's
sometimes difficult when you're working
with a another organization
um so that was really positive and we
also had a task and finish group on
looking at the budget and again there
was different members of this committee
and you as as Mr Burke said we can
invite different officers to attend for
different parts of of the process
I wonder things that Mr Perks emphasized
is that one they don't have to be on
worldly two they have to be timely
imprompt and three we really want to
know what we want from them before we
set up a task and finished group
um and obviously this is why we're
talking about task and finish group now
um
certainly it's it's a good way of
members really getting an in-depth
knowledge of of a subject uh it's called
a it's a steep learning curve at times
but it it is really positive uh and this
is one of the reasons why we try and
make a difference uh and so therefore a
small group of members supported by
officers go away probe in detail and
come back with recommendations to
overview and scooter the committee is
that right Mr Perks who will then go
back to
um cabinet and potentially full Council
yes in this instance if it's a notice on
motion it would have come through the I
think this one came through the cabinet
or it came through the camera to the
cabinet they've asked you to sort of
give some scrutiny to it so as they they
can report back to forecast with finding
so it's it's the opportunity to sort of
actually do the donkey work I suppose
and get to the bottom of the issue and
sort of make some recommendations that
can inform our sort of work program
going forward
sorry about that failed again
it's a bit like being on mute when
you're on the zooms or teams meeting
isn't it talking about loads of sensible
stuff and by the time you you come back
on you've forgotten what you were saying
so
um that's my excuse anyway so I think
I we're asking members to decide where
how we progress this not just a motion
uh to do with housing associations
because I do know that a lot of my
casework still relates to housing
associations
um
so
I think really we need to look
because it could be such a big area I
think we need to decide what we're
likely to concentrate upon that will
make the most difference in the with the
limited amount of time and officer time
availability because
the more obviously time we take on this
process is
that away from their day job
so it is a fine balance of them meeting
uh responses to the members of the
public but also us being um trying to
hold the house and associations to
account and finding reasons why and
getting to know
what our members of the public issues
are you know we've got a good idea but
um I think
today the example from bromford was
quite good they were responsive to our
questions and and touched on some ideas
and again when we get the information
the power points I think we could use
some of that is our prayer bring to
other housing associations as well so
again
um even some form of Benchmark and our
own internal benchmarking but that's not
you know might be slightly going off off
piece there against the Hurricanes I can
see you're thinking I can see I can see
you you want to say something so I'm
happy for you to come in now give my
your voice a rest as well
but whether this is
this is I'm not entirely
I'm not entirely sure but that's for for
officers to think about because the
asking the council the questions that
you have here and of course Council
fastly come come back to me these are
not unreasonable asks just here are they
that those things can be arranged do we
need a task and finish group for that
for that to happen or can it can it
just happen I'm a bit confused as to why
there's such a time lag from this
proposal to here thank you
yeah I'm picking up the second Point
first I think the time lag is probably
due to the the changing of
administration and the elections and
it's all got rather caught up in that
because you're right emotion shouldn't
really take from December to now to sort
of be considering what we're doing with
it it is the notice on motion processes
due to our constitution a little bit
cumbersome because it has to go through
various sort of channels but it wouldn't
normally have taken that long so I think
that that's a very fair point I think
we're a task and finished group I've
just re-reads the motion which just in
case anybody doesn't say it's on page 37
um where a test can finish group might
add some value here is to sort of get to
the reality of sort of what happens
um sometimes notices on motion can be an
opportunity to express frustration
um and what the tax companies Group
which we can accept at face value
um I suspect the reality is that a lot
of this is sort of being attended to but
perhaps could be done a little bit
better and that's the sort of work that
the task companies group could unpick I
could make some offices available to you
we can get the context of the housing
associations in a sort of informal
setting and we can talk through well
what why does this happen we can talk
through some examples we can get some
clarity to members about what is being
done and then there may be that there
are routes that already exist that
people aren't aware of that's the sort
of thing I'd be looking for a tasking
finish group to tease out so that we
tried to sort of make some practical
improvements that we should make a
difference to our residents
Mr plants please
yeah excellent thank you and to answer
councilor Wally hoggin's question and
also to add to what Tony said the reason
for the delay was really I was involved
with a chat with um
councilor crum in the interim period
between December and the elections and
it was around this how would this look
in terms of a process because although
we had the guy in from bromford this
morning and actually the last
osc had orbit in this this chair at the
same time I think the difficulty for you
as a group would be that whilst there
was a presentation that you saw this
morning that went out to the world wide
web and all those millions of viewers as
you said councilor Crump
um I think if you try and get them all
in the room together
it will become very very
um I'm a dine let's put it let's put it
like that and and also I suspect
there'll be one or two who may rail
against coming in the room with others
as well so um that's not that's not so I
think that that was a bit of a
difficulty in times of thinking how
could we do this and actually I think as
Tony just said I think as a as a task
and finish group that might be tricky
for you as well because if you're going
to pick on the seven or eight register
registered social providers and get them
in and then Paul Howard's got to arrange
you all that and and to get them in
in terms of a time frame that could be
quite prohibitive as well so I think
it's really a question of that as you
said counselor Crump it's trying to hone
in on exactly what you want them or you
want from them and then try to shape it
from there because even if you know even
with the best will in the world if you
get them all in in the procession
it's still going to take you seven
months to get to the end of it assuming
that they all turn up in in the right
order and then you've got to do some
work after it and because I do think
that you will really struggle to get
them all in here on one given Friday and
certainly to get anything
this is not being disrespectful to any
of them but anything meaningful that you
could probably take from them I think
that would be my my view
cancer noise please
the thing that occurs to me based on Mr
Bennett's presentation when he was
comparing his experience at his previous
Housing Association with his current
Housing Association
with the number of
residents that were looked after by a
single coach compared to what it
experienced in the past it occurred to
me that what might be useful would be
some kind of best practice framework
that could be applied to all the housing
associations we deal with by asking all
of them how they deal with certain key
aspects of the service they provide
that may be too big a remit I'm not sure
but possibly
it would require interviewing them
separately
um over a period of time and then maybe
putting together a report of which parts
of their service we think are best
practice for the sector
it's just a thought
that's what happens please
right I've taken on board what you've
said Mr Platts and of course you Mr
Perks
um May I but
I'm going back to this overview the
overview the need for overview and
scrutiny that's for the task and finish
group for this
I think basically we need to pull this
back to the basics here as to how we
make this work better I'm certainly not
one for pulling in people week after
week and doing this it's just not
conducive we know what we want the
housing associations to do we want them
to be better and more accessible to us
and to their residents that that is the
bottom line here the purpose so looking
at the notes on motion and what about
the Housing Association
um if I might be
a little bit not disrespectful but
actually we need to tell the housing
associations what we want from them okay
moving forward not them giving us
answers to how many showers did you fit
last week and and how many
you know this is your requirements are
housing providers in Stratford and Haven
this is what we want you to do so if
we're going to have a task and finish
group I wouldn't be wanting a parade of
people coming in I'd actually want um a
coming together of minds and hearts as
to you know with a sense of
reasonableness from the officers as to
as to what we want them to do like today
I spoke spoke to that gentleman and said
you know designated contact people for
counselors that that kind of thing I
don't think that that is a big ask I
don't think that the housing
association's providers could could push
back against that but we need to be
smarter with this not dragging it out
anymore that that is really where I'm at
with this tell them what not tell them
give them our expectations of them and
then say to them you've got three months
two weeks whatever to turn this around
thank you so much for listening to that
through the chat an effective way of
dealing with that might be picking up
sort of David's point that we've got
seven or eight of them we have existing
channels of communication with the
housing associations
um I'm not suggesting that that's
perfect because we wouldn't be having
the no sun motion but if we could work
with a small group of members to make
sure that we maximize the use of those
channels rather than summoning seven or
eight people in here for a parade which
is likely to be ineffective if we can
try and get under the skin with a group
of what it is that would actually make a
difference to Residents and members and
try and use those channels to get that
to the housing associations get a
commitment from them through there that
we could bring back to the committee
that might be a way of squaring that
Circle
that's all right sorry
um yes I I what occurs to me though is
what do we expect of them and that's why
I was suggesting a best practice because
if we know it can be achieved by one
particular Housing Association then we
can ask the others to follow suit
what's we can't do it seems to me and
I'm certainly not in a position to do is
to say we expect you to answer phone
calls within two minutes we expect you
to go around within one day or whatever
unless
other associations are doing that and it
can be achieved
that was the reason why I was thinking
about best practice and not necessarily
having them all parading in but talking
to them individually
cancel that Lord please
uh thank you chair
um yes I take on board what council of
rice has said but I think we need to go
back to what uh Council Willie hoggins
was saying we we are aware of where the
real problems are we're not going to it
is a pointless task trying to solve
everything all at the same time we need
to hone in on our
first priority
to to to solve that one and then we can
move on to the the ones that are less
important until we get to a standard
boost we're happy with and it's not
going to be us to dictate I don't think
but we do have an expectation their
customers their tenants have an
expectation and I don't think it's
unreasonable that we we prioritize what
we think is the issue and let them know
and then work with them to improve
there's a couple things I will bring Mr
Perks in again in a minute
um I think there's a couple of things
here
I'm sure we could get their standards on
response times Etc from them I don't
think that'd be too difficult from them
and then the working group could assess
lives and see what their standards are
where there's any inconsistencies
and then have a deeper dive to why
um those standards are different if they
happen to be different I think we also
need to make sure that as part of the
Motions we believe this Council must
hold associations accountable
so again I think we need to really deep
dig down into what
we mean by accountable and how much
influence have we got on these
housing associations
and seek to influence what we can
influence
and find other ways where we those areas
where we've got little influence
um how we can improve that influence as
well so I think there's lots of things
on that point that
I still think a task and finish group
would be beneficial because there's
still a lot of misunderstanding of what
we're talking about or or what we can
encounter or what
you know after it's on the gdpr issue
and that is one of my biggest bug bears
and I try to hide it as best as I can
but it didn't I don't always succeed
um
so I think we need to look at that so
I'll bring Mr Perks and Mr Platts
thank you chairman yeah what I'm sort of
picking up from the discussion which is
really useful for me is there I think
there is a point in establishing sort of
best practice I think that's absolutely
right cancel the rice and what I'm
I think as officers we can help you with
that because if we sort of use best
practice with a small b as opposed to
sort of a fixed term what we will know
is which housing associations are good
at which bits
and where I think local government works
best is we've got professional officers
working with representative of the
community Through members and you as
members you're hearing in your post
boxes your inboxes as we have these days
sort of What the residents are
complaining about so if we had a bit of
a comparison with what you're hearing on
on the street with what officers are
finding from knowing oh this one's good
at answering calls that one's good at
doing repairs that one's good at fixing
boilers and sort of heating and that
sort of stuff if we could somehow pull
that together to make a sort of well why
don't we get so if we shared that sort
of sort of best practice with a small B
between the housing associations we're
working with picking up the residence
points picking up the expertise of
officers I think that would move us
forward and we would be creating
something valuable out of it
um and I think that would be achievable
within a small group that we do have to
bear in mind we aren't sort of the
regulator of housing associations here
so we're using soft power and influence
rather than we can't I'm slightly
concerned with this sort of old housing
associations to account sort of type
term because at the end of the day if
they if they choose not to do it and and
they're not breaching their code with
the Ombudsman there's probably not a
great deal that we can enforce but that
doesn't mean we shouldn't try and make
things better so it's it's setting
realistic aims and and approaching it
from a constructive way rather than a
regulatory I think
yeah all I was going to say we to add to
what Tony just said really we can
facilitate that because um
the residents who contact you are the
same residents who contact us because
they've been in touch with orbit or
they've been in touch with bromford they
haven't got anywhere so they're coming
to us to kind of can you help me so so
again we could ask all members to
provide
I'm going to give you the job here
Howard
but how we could sort of collate the the
information that you guys have all got
and then through the contact center
anybody who contacts us about a
complaint with any of them about any of
their properties we'll have that and to
add to what Tony said it will be about I
have my boiler fixed I haven't had the a
service to my central heat whatever but
that might then give us that sort of
template where we can say well we know
that a B and C are good at boiler
repairs DNA for rubbish and and it might
help give us an Evidence base that you
could at least start with I think and
say they would certainly be the that
they would be the the good examples to
look at because they've tried to get
hold of their registered social provider
who has not either delivered or provided
them with what they expected and that's
why they're contacting us because
they're looking for us to give it some
more umph and that's yourselves Anderson
as an organization I think so that might
be another starting point
yeah it's just building that story what
it would give you is an Evidence base
because it's all too easy to knock off
like oh it's just a an extremist who
doesn't get their boiling picks they're
scrambling so we'll dismiss that if
we've got a collection of sort of 20 30
cases and we can show a pattern then
it's more difficult for the Housing
Association to brush that away so I
think that's one thing that we could
achieve
yeah and again we touched on it earlier
about
in my ward
um the point about oh this is in my ward
whereas if it's again if it's consistent
throughout
the whole of the district we need to be
looking at that
so again I think
I don't think it'll be particularly
onerous but I think we
we need to make clear what we can
influence how we implement
you know looking at the notice of motion
there does seem to be
some slight misunderstanding of what we
can and can't do
um
but I think we as counselors have a duty
to our residents and particular those in
social housing affordable housing
whatever term we want to use
that we value them and we will look
after those just as much as anybody else
and sometimes
um we need to make special emphasis on
the vulnerable people in social housing
um who can't look after themselves who
haven't got a voice who are being
um having trouble getting in touch with
with that
the landlord and the issues around how
much credit they've got how difficult it
is to get through and again
some of these things that might be
slightly outside of the remit but I
think they're going to be more important
and I think
we're sort of like focusing
the notice the motion into areas what
our residents want us to look at so
um
and I think it might not be as difficult
as I think it is
until we have a look
um we might have to do this quite
quickly but until we've had a quick look
and that's because there's still some
uncertainties that's my only thing and
like we've had no just emotions again
for more parties
um I think Larry Clues
can be equally as Vic and then notice of
motions irrespective of what parties so
again I've got no criticism will notice
of motion but I think we can use this as
a catalyst
to go into the Tuscan finish group to
find some of the things that our
residents want and us as members find
frustrated gdpr
um and and also you know various other
things that we should be knowing or will
be good for us to know
to make our lives just catch those
easier such as the contact who does what
who does where and what we can influence
as well because we need to spend our
time wiser both officer time and
ourselves because we you know our inbox
keeps on getting Fuller and Fuller um
and we if we can
work more efficiently get that inbox
down
make the registered social landlords
um work to improve their customer
service and customer level satisfaction
it will certainly make our lives a lot
easier and offices lives easier
slightly Rumble done but hopefully I've
quite made the point on wanting to know
that
any any other comments Mr Smokes
councilwale Huggins first
I don't disagree with what with what
you're saying but I still it still comes
down to the final point that says the
council needs to exert influence and
demands better from housing associations
for our residents and in connection with
that I would say that one of the things
that we need to be looking at as a
council for our residents intended or
social housing is to look at our golden
rules of expectations for our for our
housing at
housing associations
for example if we found that one of the
housing associations doesn't answer
telephone calls for eight minutes I
don't think that I'm prepared to average
that out for the others as well so they
need to be better than eight than eight
minutes so you know I think we have to
be um
there has to be some aspirational
targets I'm not expecting within two
minutes but there has to be some
aspirational targets within that but I
think that if we came to some sort of
this is what we expect and if they're
falling short if that is the purpose of
the task and finish group then then I
welcome it but every week and month that
we carry on not dealing with this is
another wasted opportunity and I say
that because we are halfway through the
year and winter beckons and we know that
winter is a critical point in time for
many of our residents in in social
housing with heating costs
um damp
Etc so I would I think we really need to
be smart about what we're aiming to
achieve here thank you I think again
there's some point on being smart and
working efficiently let's get we need to
get the evidence because if we've you
know the anecdotal evidence is fine but
if we can say to ex social landlord
we've got this evidence of you you know
your your response times to this or your
customer satisfaction is is why or our
customer contact center
um
it is getting loads of phone calls about
x y and z
um
and it seems to be a recurring theme why
is this you know we've told you about it
why isn't it being tackled so I think
that's when the contact center would be
pivotal to this to get the information
out and I'm sure Mr Platts is not in
there about to get all this wonderful
information so I think
the first meeting on the task and finish
group will be quite interesting but I
think we can start to get the
information and then we can focus in on
what we can and what we expect
um but if we haven't got the evidence
or you know or we've only got anecdotal
evidence
it's more difficult to hold them to
account and but that's my accountant
coming out and but I think if we got the
evidence I think that's we can make
better decisions like so then we can
um but the whole point is tasks and
finish groups is the flexibility
it doesn't involve
um you know all the members here and we
can bring in offices in when appropriate
so they don't have to come to every
meeting so
um
does that sound sensible Mr Perks
yeah so I think the decisions that we
then need to make is firstly are we
having a task and finish group that
seems that the feeling of the meeting is
that we probably are and secondly to
sort of work out who would like to be on
it and we'll facilitate that Howard will
facilitate that with the officers I'll
make sure we make people available to
the group should that be the design of
the committee
and usually
again trying to be as flexible as
possible the the meetings and sessions
can be in person and or wide by teams as
well so it's make sure people can attend
because sometimes we have lots of
different meetings but
and it helps concentrate on mind if
we've got limited amount of time
to talk about something and again if if
people do commit to beyond the task and
finish group we need to make sure they
do the work or make sure they've got
questions
or some ideas are key points of um kpis
key lines of inquiry that we're going to
want to go down so
um I'd like to see a range of
experiences on on this committee a task
and finish group
um
but whoever's on there
I'd like a commitment from them that
they will
um
do the work and attend as much as
possible so
oh
um send something out to the members who
are not here obviously we've got three
not here uh catch the Johnstone Council
Keithley and cancer Rolf
um because Kate sorry cancel the role
for has experience on the task and
finish groups as well
um so
well
she's actually interested in the topic
yeah so yeah so I think that is is
really positive so
um if you're feeling shy now
I'm more than happy to
um well how is more than happy to
coordinate and co uh
coordinate a list of volunteers
um but yeah we would look um probably
about four or five members maximum
to take this forward so thank you
so in principle we've got agreement we
will have a task and finish group
on Haze associations working around the
node to submotion but not necessarily
adhering it to a hundred percent
depending on what we find and the areas
of flexibility
and we will report back regularly to
over in scrutiny committee on the
progress of the task and finish group
and I'll now the next meeting of the
um over in scrutiny is on the 30th which
is four weeks today so I would hope
would start some make some progress by
then
were you asking for volunteers now or
yes
so we got a cunning plan there a cunning
plan of action yeah yeah I suppose if
there's anybody who's desperate to do it
and wants to raise their hand now it
would make how is like Howard's life
easier we've got cancer passing him or
otherwise that people need to check
their Diaries Howard couldn't sort of
mail out to you and do that now but if
anybody is championing at the bit I
wouldn't want to discourage you
persuaded one there we go I've got two
of them two of this yes excellent I'm
I'm doing my salesman better here but
I'm not getting much from the right hand
side but I'll leave you to it though oh
look I've got another bidder with cancer
little
excellent thank you very much
we'll talk on item number nine which is
the cabinet meeting
on the fifth of June
um
I'll propose
we have a small
suspension of the meeting because we've
just received the approval of
procurement complex needs
cabinet report today
which is going on Monday
um so I would like to give members the
opportunity to read this report
to see if they've got any comments that
we need to go back to
um cabinet with on Monday that's I will
I'll be presenting our view
um just coming along I've asked Mr
Platts to sort of stay with us Mr Platts
who's sort of the owner of this report
it's it sits in his service so if you've
got any questions of sort of detail
David will be able to help us if that
would be useful so we'll we'll have a
brief interlude and then we'll be asking
you questions Mr Platts if that's okay
because members have only just received
that
um
that's a good idea yeah
you you were less subtle than me
um yeah I think the first thing to say
is that
um
all this report is actually doing is
asking you in line with the capsules
Constitution and standing orders to
allow us to go out and do a procurement
so at this stage we're not
telling you who is going to provide this
service we're merely saying that
um we'd like to undertake a procurement
and because of the the amount of money
involved we need to get cabinet's
approval to undertake the procurement so
this is like bottom of the ladder stuff
we're just starting off with this and
the provision is for the governments
rough sleeping initiative so again this
is not a stratford-on-avon initiative
this is across all local authorities in
the UK it's been a scheme has been in
operation through central government
since 2017.
and the current funding stream from
government ends on the 31st of August
this year
the government came out to us fairly
late and said here's some more money for
the next two years and this funding from
the government is to support the
provision of services for for let's face
it the people who are some of the most
vulnerable residents across the district
the funding is ring fenced by government
for the provision of this service only
and we have to spend it if we choose not
to do anything with this then the
government are going to say well
why aren't you doing something because
you understand how complicated this work
is we and they won't you know they won't
take lightly to that so all this report
is doing is seeking your approval or
cabinet's approval to go out to the
market and procure the provision of the
service let's say we're not trying to
allocate it to anybody and to be
brutally honest with you sitting here
this morning I've got no idea who's
going to throw their hat in the ring and
say actually we'd like to to come and
provide this service for you so we're
not even at that stage I can't give you
a list of the runners and Riders even at
this point
um there isn't any additional funding
required there's an earmark reserve for
for any additional stuff that we we
might need to to deal with once the
procurement gets going the government
has announced that the initiative is a
four-year program but it's only given us
funding for the first two years and then
they're going to revisit it so what
we're doing with this procurement is
basically to say for the first two years
we'd like to go out procure the service
and then there would be an option to
extend at the end of the two years once
we get the guarantee from government
that that further funding is coming
forward so all this is doing it's really
just saying under starters orders let's
go out for a procurement and because of
the amount of money involved our cabinet
happy to support it
right so I will now give members the
option whether they want a a deferral of
the meeting sorry um the suspension of
the meeting to read the report or are
they happy to ask Mr Platt's questions
no
okay
we will
have a small suspension of the meeting
for
to read the meeting or for other issues
that have just cropped up
um
it's
and then we'll be asking Mr Platt some
questions
thank you
foreign
engines of the administration which we
will hopefully have now moved through
and we'll be getting the reports out in
a timely fashion for scrutiny going
forward
so I'm I'm aware that it's um it's not
good practice to deliver reports to you
this late hour and expect you to comment
on them
um in this instance I hope we've invited
Mr Platts to join you to give some
reassurance that I don't think there's
any sort of huge risk but were the
reports have been more significant we
would probably have had to sort of Pull
It And Delay it but I'm hopeful in this
instance we can sort of keep this one
moving
okay it's passing them please
how will this affect the Fred winter
Center is it part of funding for the
Fred winter or it's totally different
it's a it's a completely different set
of funding the Fred winter Center
funding is already allocated
Etc so this is it's not to say that some
of the support services helping some of
the individuals who'll be covered by
this uh won't be hosted or run from the
Fred winter Center but in terms of the
funding they're two completely separate
things
Fred winter Center
funded just through Council funds then
without any government
there are no central government grants
for Fred winter Center but there are
other Financial contributions from
County Council and Town Council Etc so
yeah
councilor rice please
yes I have two questions
um firstly I'm curious about the
nomenclature
complex need service doesn't suggest to
me homelessness and I notice only for
homeless people with complex needs I
wonder about homeless people without
complex needs
um my second question
um refers to
you use the word create in the reports
which suggests something other than a
procurement process and the options
available to the cabinet are recommended
to approve the recommended
procurement process or to suggest an
alternative well as far as I can see
there's no
procurement process
specified in the report and I want I'm
curious to know what and the alternative
might be
well the the procurement is the
government's rough sleeper initiative
that is the title of the procurement so
central government have said here's some
money
um and the procurement process itself is
stipulated
by the government in terms of this
particular funding part but also we
include as I say our own procurement
process through standing orders that we
do with any external procurement because
we're not doing this ourselves
so um the process that we're going
through is as I stipulated both by
central government and by the council's
own standing orders and Constitution
so but what is the alternative then oh I
suspect the alternative would be that um
we would decide not to do it so we said
we're not bothered about the rough
sleepers we'll just not use this money
uh so we certainly couldn't spend it on
something else the money has to be ring
fenced as part of this or it may well be
that
cabinet decided that they wanted to
undertake some other
delivery of this scheme in some way
shape or form depending on what that
might be
and the name
sorry the first my first question which
you haven't answered sorry complex need
service doesn't suggest to me
homelessness and it only refers to
homeless people with complex needs
sorry
I I can pick that up um
there are a variety of reasons that
people are homeless some people are
homeless because they get sort of
discharged in their private landlords
and things like that but they've got
relatively stable Lifestyles and we have
initiatives to deal with those this
particular initiative is to deal with
people with what we call complex needs
which are people who are generally sort
of living on the streets the rough
sleeping would be another nomenclature
you could use for it so there are
different categories or different
different reasons for homelessness in
this particular initiative is aimed at
those with particularly complex needs
which tend to be the rough sleepers so I
think that that hopefully that makes
sense now
okay cancel the rice thank you
yeah did you want to come back cancer
while they have against
just to help you counselor ice that the
complex needs of these rough sleepers
are a huge there's drug dependency
there's refusals there's alcohol
dependency so just finding them a house
or a property or a place to live isn't
actually enough what they need is a
multi-agency approach in order to
prevent them from making themselves
homeless again I think I've got that
about about right here and during the
lock covered lockdown
um this really came to the four that it
was these complex needs of the
individuals that was actually holding
them back from actually successfully
transitioning in in into homes so it is
an expensive
um program but it will pay dividends in
the long term so yes I fully
um I want to place a record that I fully
agree with the title of this procurement
that I think that that adequately
explains what it is that the procurement
is about and I thank you Mr Platts for
this report thank you
yep thank you Mr Patsy it's really
helpful it is
it it must be
a particular
subject that
the government is aware of to provide
this funding
um should be for four years and
obviously we've only got the funding
guaranteed for two years and with the
extension
um of the service
provision after the two years so I can
understand how difficult it is going to
be and the reasons why it's being
brought forward because it's over 150
000 procurement limit
um so I think that that has really
helped and explains the situation
I think some general point I'd like to
make is that you know we are in the in
the early blooming of the administration
and I can understand the situation so
yeah I think we can give some leeway
but I wouldn't and I think this report
is does what it says on the tin it's not
particularly contentious we're not
finding funding ourselves
and it's it's a particularly complex
subject obviously the complex need
um so I think that is a you know is a
proper report one explained but I don't
think it was too
too complicated so I'm slightly
disappointed that we're only receiving
this report now today
and if it had been under the previous
administration I would have still
expressed my disappointment
because we want to make sure over in
school overview and scrutiny committee
does its best
unscrutinizes these things in detail
and as we explained when we had the
registered social landlord here the
better answers we got to the questions
were the ones that we gave notice of
so we do need time to read and digest
and ask the questions and I don't think
we missed any serious questions here
because it wasn't a complex report and
that's again no pun intended but if
we're going to get another report
that's more complex got more issues we
do need to make sure we've got time to
do this so we can scrutinize effectively
so
I think we just need to make that point
in a reasonable way you know we'll say
we can understand the reasoning and but
I think we need to give notice that we
do need and we expect as a scrutiny
committee information that the earliest
opportunity so we can discuss in detail
Tuesday at different points and raise
issues with cabinet that I can raise
issues a cabinet on your behalf
um at the next following meter
with you so
feel free to go Mr plastic if that's
okay
oh sorry cancel this word yeah
thank you Mr chairman and I realize you
need to go quickly so I'll make this uh
quick I mean it is a complex
um issue uh and I'm I'm looking at this
and what I would like to understand
because of the complexity we're talking
about in the report 1.8
um you're talking about b b
accommodation you're talking about other
accommodations and processes it doesn't
mention any of the other Associated
services and agencies that need to to be
brought into this highly complex what is
the process for
um making sure that we get best value
for money in such a complex situation
please
obviously once we get the responses in
to the tenders we will then run it
through the council's best value to to
ensure that the all the tenders are
considered
um all the details both financially and
more crucially in this situation as
councilor Wally hoggins has said that
the complexity around some of the
chaotic lifestyles of of these
individuals these residents have to be
fully met so we will be using our own
Legal Services we'll be using expert
um external helpers into in terms of
investigating each of the tenders that
comes in each of the responses that
comes in to make sure that the council
does get the best value
possibly with um saying that we've got
quite developed procurements at the
processes that are set out within
Constitution which is probably worth um
people use this to look through so the
way that we procure and determine is
determined by the value of the contract
whether you get three quotes whether you
go to a sort of all tender how much we
have to advertise and a lot of that is
sort of governed by legislation
um what we prefer to do for anything
other than the most simple complex
contracts which we would just do on
Price is this sort of it's like a cost
quality split and it's a the term we use
is this meat most economically
advantageous terms so you've got a
combination of obviously you don't want
the cheapest service here you want the
one that's going to sort of get the best
value for your money so we have an
appraisal method where you get different
points for different criteria and
there's some together so as we try and
work out which is the best value
contractors business or the cheapest or
the the one that meets the brief best
but that that set out in the
Constitution and I'm more than happy to
talk you through that sometime when
you've got half an hour to spare
so I think we note we note the report
um
we've scrutinized and questioned uh the
funding of the report
um
obviously it can be more difficult even
though it's a four-year scheme we've got
two years funding guaranteed so again
well that's not not good for staff
and planning we've got the flexibility
of the procurement extended
to couple the terms
um so I think
you know the council
um will be foolish not to accept the
funding
um to spend on a particularly complex
needs area of vulnerable residents
um and note the good work that um that
even though
um
there are four
um and the numbers are consistently
below four at times
um
we still strive to ensure that number is
is close to zero as possible so I think
that's I think that's positive and the
other point is that again from scrutiny
point of view we would need to
as much noticed as possible and
receiving
um
a report on the day of the meeting is
not really acceptable but on this
occasion we can understand what we would
wish it not to happen again
is that a first summary
brilliant thank you
good stuff so we wanted to go back to
the work program
which is item number five oh the second
oh so I was trying to be able to swiftly
on I do apologize
I do
um
yes it's the 2023 year-end performance
report
um
yes Mr Perks if you want to bring this
please thank you chairman um yes what
you have here is a fairly standard
report for those with the first time
this committee has seen it
um we run a council plan which sets out
the objectives for the council for four
years
um the current council plan runs until
October and one of the things that we're
doing with the new Administration is
sort of working out what the new council
plan will look like for the next four
years and within that we do an annual
action plan for how that plan is
delivered and contained within that
annual action plan or a number of
performance indicators which is what
you're seeing reported to you today from
memory they come to the overview in
scrutinally committee quarterly so you
can see how things are progressing on
the annual plans this is the final set
of indicators on
um the current council plan before we
move to the new plan which we're
currently starting to develop they're
set out in the the tables so you'll see
the the objective priority is is how it
relates back to the the council plan and
which aspect of the council planet is
there are a series of tasks there are
targets and there are status and some
comments
um the report other than that I think
largely speaks for itself
um if you've got any particular
questions on it I'll do my best to
answer them on the grounds that also
ended up reporting to me but if it's
anything very specific I might need to
defer to get some feedback from my head
of services relevant but I'm very happy
to take any questions
while you're thinking of some questions
or any notes
um I noticed the development of the
Gateway master plan to determine the
development of the world Shakespeare
centers
is in a couple of areas it's both in
cp1a
and uh
cp2a not C3PO
um so certainly there's that seems to be
ongoing so there's obviously some form
of cross
cross responsibility on that so again
some explanation of that it doesn't make
sense but again it just seemed to be in
two performance areas and if it fails in
one performance area it's like it's 2002
so while we sit in ourselves up to to
fail
um cp1c
the city of culture and the bomb
um Birmingham Commonwealth Games we've
touched on about
um the city of culture before and the
Legacy and
um
the company that went into
Administration
um but I believe you know there's no
impact as such on on the district
but when we're looking at the
um it'd be interesting to see the the
benefits
um we mentioned the No Strings badminton
at Stratford Leisure Center
um the Greg Leisure Center which seems
to be in the west of the district and
again perhaps it'd be interesting to see
the benefits towards the east of the
district as well
um
I did like the title No string strings
badminton
um so I think that's that's quite a good
idea I do like that one so um
again again we need to consider that
um the legacy of such schemes is
consistent or really really fair
relatively Fair across across the
district
uh
I did do my homework so I've been doing
some
um
there's one close to my own heart
towards the open space
contribution inside them that is see
p2b
um
yeah it's about local opposition on that
I think you know we could be more
specific I think the the Town Council
of write some issues I've not been made
aware of
um
issues from from residents on that one
so again
um if we can that's close to my own
heart if we can progress that one
um
feel free to jump in any time if I've
got some issues
um cp2e
um
increase the level on quality of
broadband coverage
again I'm sure some of our members are
already receiving complaints about uh
the broadband
uh contractors
okay yeah
um and how
there are communication issues
um
the roads and pasta being dug up several
times and somebody coming out and
digging up what they've dug up before
um and whether we can make sure
whilst I accept the the quality in
Broadband coverage
uh needs to be improved in our issues to
do well I think it was the copper
Broadband wasn't it
um I mean you saw in our raw all hours
in particular whether Broadband isn't
great
we need to make sure it's it's done been
done in the best way and also that our
residents are inconvenienced in the
least possible way
um because it's
it's not good
um so again do we need to speak to
um how we can work with BD UK to to
ensure that the fire Railways is managed
efficiently and effectively
and with the minimum inconvenience to
our residents
particularly around schools and and and
hospitals or or community centers where
where people need access as much as they
can
um
it'll be interesting as well
um South Yorkshire local plan
on cp3b
um it'd be good to see how that
progresses
um bearing in mind
um the two main drivers of the safe or
actually a local plan
are no longer the role in Administration
in in either District so um be
interesting to see how that works
um because there's always been on that
local plan group and lots of good work
has been done and has been benefits from
officers working together
ourselves and it has made savings so I
can see the benefits of that Cancer pass
income you've come in and saved me save
my voice now
yeah there's a letter in the Herald
from the
saying that the joint or advocating that
the joint
saturity plan should be scrapped and we
should go back to individual ones
uh is that is that something that is
worth discussing or is or is it a fake
company now that we're we're into a
joint
um South Warwickshire local plan
I think it's it's the scrutiny committee
obviously we're talking about
performance reports it could be a future
work plan item
um
it could be you know we we could ask the
administration what their views are
on the future of the local plans whether
they will be an individual on world
where they will carry on with the with
the joint one with Warwick District
um because
we don't know and obviously when people
don't know things they tend to feel the
information Gap with their own with
their own views which are not
necessarily always accurate if it is on
the table it ought to be discussed
quickly because otherwise there'll be a
lot of wasted time won't it
[Music]
um
yeah from what I understand that the
intention is for the South Forest local
plan to continue to visit a joint
exercise we're in discussions with the
the new administration at Warwick
District you seem to be supportive of
that so at least the research elements
of it and the sort of early phases of it
continues sort of jointly it's long-term
future to the player in due course in
terms of the cpre letter
um the cpre arms and electric body they
are a pressure group who sort of holds
certain views about local plans some of
which
various people describe subscribe to
um but yes they they would in Democratic
returns to be subservant subservient to
an elected body but they are using the
opportunity to make their opinion heard
should the administrations at either
place choose to take that view that's
their prerogative but as I understand it
at the moment the work is planning to
continue joining for the time being so I
wasn't advocating that it'd be scrapped
I just was curious as to whether
um the administration and and the
officers thought it was practical to
carry on with it or or whether it was
just burdensome bureaucracy that that
was being created with it I I don't know
the the rationale for creating it
jointly hasn't changed and that there's
a function of economic geography and
there's a common interest of sort of
working in South Warwick in terms of
communication sustainability and sort of
the broader economy so those factors are
still there
um it's it would be within the gift of
either Administration to sort of decide
to sort of go their separate ways but
the early signings I've had is that
they're both minded to continue for the
time being
first of all Huggins
yeah I'm just looking at cp5a which is
the um particularly the the con to
continue with the compulsory purchase
order am I right in thinking that that's
coming to a critical head this September
Mr Perks please
yes in terms of the wellsborn Airfield
development we still have the
outstanding sort of potential to
compulsory purchase the site on the
books at the moment
um where we are
um I'm trying to look at how much this I
need to say so it makes sense the
committee without keeping here or
morning
um one of the policies in our course
strategy as-9 seeks to preserve Aviation
at wellsborn Airfield that appeared once
said to be under threat and so the
cabinet
um resolved that we could use compulsory
purchase powers to sort of bring that
into Stratford's ownership to keep
Aviation operative in terms of as9 and
our core strategy as part of the
compulsory purchase process you need to
engage with the owners of the Lamb to
see if you can achieve that aims through
other ways without compulsory purchase
which is effectively a thing of Last
Resorts in summary
we have worked with the owners of the
the land at the Airfield and what
um cancer Wally hoggins alludes to is in
September we're expecting a planning
application for the development of the
site that would see Aviation preserved
and also be acceptable to the landowners
now if that's found to be acceptable and
sort of those common agreements that we
would no longer each compulsory purchase
the science of the motive for doing it
would have passed
um so yes that's quite a long way round
of answering your question if it's
coming to a head in September and the
need or not need for compulsion
production should be determined
cancel this lower plan
um Jim before that item came up I should
have uh declared an interest as my wife
is a finance director of one of the
companies on the wells born side
now that that's fine thank you that's
not it thank you
um
I've got some other there seem to be
some general themes coming through
um the performance is this aerial works
not progressed at present due to lack of
resourcing that that seems to be
I can see three or four
um
especially under I think it was cp5b
C Etc there's a few under them there's
other ones to do with vacancies on the
DFG on
um one of the priorities and kpis key
performance indicators sorry
um
what are we doing because it was touched
on as part of the bromford speech as
well presentation that Recruitment and
Retention of Staff
um
because obviously
um if Ram problems recruiting and
retaining staff that's going to have a
knock-on effect on our customer
performance
um so I think that's wondering issues
and I know just that we didn't quite
achieve our
sickness substance Target
of some a target of 7.5 days and it was
8.16 which isn't particularly much over
um
so again I think that seemed to be
getting worse as well from memory so I
think we need to ensure
we recruit and return staff
and replace effectively when obviously
we have because we've got Mr Platt
sleeve in the Mr Grafton and we've got
two new two new heads of service so the
process does seem to be working but I
think with like some reassurance
that staff are our most important assets
so therefore we need to make sure we
value on keep them so therefore again we
can respond to our customers so just
some Assurance about that please
yes I think it's fair to say that
recruitments and retention of stuff is
challenging at the moment the labor
market is quite
um sort of seller Centric at the minute
um and it is difficult to attract people
in and also I think the sort of the
increases of hybrid working is meant you
can work in a much broader part of the
country now
um and it is
we've offered positions to people over a
construction manager at the moment I
offered a position to accept it and has
now sort of declined so it is it is a
challenge for us um I think your rights
to raise that as an issue as an open
security committee the two specific
um examples that you gave from the kpis
chairman one related to publicity and
the view magazine now that was a
specific issue that we we really have
one member of Staff in that area who's
been with us for years and has been very
loyal and very very good she's had a
sort of quite a significant illness
that's just one of those things that
occasionally happens and she's been off
a couple a month so she's back working
now back up to speed again but
unfortunately in her absence we were
unable to sort of deliver the The View
magazine
um that again was further Complicated by
the fact that the people who did the
view magazine for a sec certainly went
bust at the same time so that that's
there's a little bit more to that one
than sort of meets the eye on there and
we are looking to be more resilient in
that area
um following the demerger with Warwick
we're going on a more Standalone version
so that's the sort of a bit of a
conspiracy of things coming together
in terms of the um the FG grants we're
part of the heart partnership that's
been quite extensively scrutinized by
this committee over the last 12 months
we have looked at some other options for
sort of doing that again that's a little
more complicated than meets the eye
because we're restricted by central
government budgets of how much money
we've got to spend on it so we we could
arguably spend it quicker and then wait
or spread it out but I think that's been
quite well explored by these committees
who've decided that what's what we've
got isn't perfect it's probably the best
that we can achieve the time being and
the message that we got back from the
scrutiny committee and the cabinet was
to sort of keep going with the existing
Arrangements but keep a closer eye on
them which is what we pursue at the
moment so they'll no doubt be further
reports back to you as the year goes on
because we've slightly changed the
arrangement of the heart Partnerships
trying to improve that but it did seem
that perhaps the best of a bad job is
not the best way to describe it but you
know what I mean
please yes may I follow up on that
um I've linked three items not achieved
under uh cp5b
one of which was the view magazine which
you say was to do with Staffing
I note that it's actually in the
appendix as lack of resourcing
and then the other two that I've linked
with it
are the consider the future of social
use of social media
and also Implement a media in public
relations strategy both of those were
due to a lack of resourcing so I suppose
my question is
why are they in the action plan if they
cannot be resourced
there's two answers to that and a third
solution which I'll offer
The View magazine as a that they do
relate largely to their long-term
absence of the our publicity officer who
was away for several months with with
this sort of illness that she suffered
and they were in her work program but it
was a single point of failure
um we do have reactive cover Through
Warwickshire County Council super City
press releases but the proactive work is
is reliant on the one member of staff
The View magazine was further
complicated because we outsourced that
and the company who
um delivered that for us and I've done
for many years went into liquidation so
they were unable to deliver that we are
currently talking to an alternative
provider the one who provided the witch
Haven magazine so that there are we've
got stuff in place there
the social media and the media strategy
as I say would have been sort of in the
publicity officer's work program
um so that's why they've not been
delivered because we haven't had a
proactive resource in that area and we
have
um had clearance from the cabinet now to
sort of reinforce that team so we would
have two officers there sort of going
forward
um we we've flirted between one and two
offices depending on sort of the budget
settlements over the years but we're
looking to take that team back to two
so hopefully they'll be better going
forward
okay so I actually got another question
um yes and that also covers the media
and public relations strategy
thank you um I think it's probably going
to be my last one
um
and again we've touched on obviously one
of the companies going to Administration
for
uh you know part of Perfect Storm to do
with the view
um I'll see the percentages of nnd are
collected
um
was
down just under four percent
um from 98.2 to 94.3
um
it'd be interesting to find out
obviously I'm sure we're part of a pool
not with any of the art pool
um it'd be interesting to see what our
share of that underperformance is or is
it still going to be our residential
rolled over a number of years like it
used to be so it'll be quite interesting
to see what the financial effect is
but the wider point is that
we would need to be asking
what the administration's plans are to
support businesses
um
drawn the cost of living crisis
to make sure the employment comes in to
make sure we get the nndr and make sure
um we've got to thrive in healthy
economy I think I think I would be the
point on that a couple of points on that
one thank you
yeah I
beyond the fact that we're in a business
rates pool you're at the edge of my sort
of technical detail of nndr so I'll get
you an answer outside dimension on that
one oddly Dave Platts leads on that area
for me but it's a
he's had to leave us
um
yes I I think you're right it'd be
interesting instead of the new the the
previous cancer plan was very much
stressed around sort of supporting
business supporting the economy
um we're yet to see what the plans for
the new Administration
state but I think if that is a concern
of the committee it would be good to
feed that in so that in informs that
process
any more questions on that
so I almost skipped over that
performance and report and I would have
saved us 20 minutes but I thought we
thought we need need to do that
um going quickly back on to the item
five the work plan that we've moved to
the end of the meeting which I thought
was pertinent in light of all the
discussions we're going to be having and
we had
which is on
page 33-36
I'll need to need an extra pair of hands
on this
um
the next
gone how would you want to go
do you want to yeah bring those in then
um yes so this this version of the work
plan was agreed by the previous
committee
um because the change of our
Administration the me and the chair of
discussed a number of changes one of
which is shuffling the cabinet member
question time around a little bit to
make sure that the cabinet members with
these specific portfolios are sort of
settled in and know the portfolio as
well so we're proposing that the first
Cabinet member to be invited is going to
be constituted and
um that'll be probably in September
um
and and we've also discussed a number of
other items we're carrying forward
um of course housing we've we've
discussed today in detail
um so this housing task and finish group
now we decided we're going to carry on
with that and carrying on to invite
housing associations whether that be one
by one or together that's for the task
and finish group to look into further
and also one issue that we've been well
two issues really with the same body
um the integrated the ICB or ICP
integrated care board or integrated care
partnership we are looking to invite
them as soon as possible to talk
specifically about the health care
facility at upper lighthorne and also to
talk about the beds review at the nickel
unit in Stratford and the shipston
hospital Ellen Badger hospital as well
have um I'm sorry Council fragile has
got some points he wants to bring up to
do with future so if you can lays with
uh Howard about those
you put your microphone on please
I agreed with how did I send him
something when I got home so to speak
yeah that's brilliant and the next
meeting we can then integrate them I
know as part of a work plan you know
we'll be talking about the Tuscan finish
group as well and the next meeting the
cabinet
um
following sorry I've got something in
the eye at the next meeting of the
cabinet which is just after our meeting
on the 30th of June has got
um I think 14 items on the agenda some
of which might not go there
um but I think one of them was
um the future of Elizabeth thanks is
that going to be on that one yes that
will be on that one
um so I think there will be lots for us
to
um talk about obviously on this cabinet
one you know we've spoken for about half
an hour on two small items smallest
items so I think we need to give
ourselves plenty of time at the next
meeting and look at those and then we
really start to hit the ground running
after that meeting so I think first got
the meetings gives ourselves a bit of
leeway discuss the issues get used to
what we're doing
and then then really
um
really concentrate on our questions and
how we're going to deal with our
scrutiny of the council effectively so I
think if members are happy with that I
think that's a sensible approach
um I think we've got a lot out of today
um
and I think you know it's it's been
really positive but like I said I don't
want to scare people off too much in the
first couple of sessions
um so this is the nice cuddly Andy crumb
that you you don't normally see
so uh yeah no no I'm not that bad honest
um so um I think that is really positive
I think we've got some ideas for the
work plan
um and then we need to get that task and
finish group off off and ready off and
running as soon as possible
so
uh
Mr Perks you want to come in on that
please oh I was just working so there is
none to Urgent business
brilliant so thank you very much
so no urgent business and I know can't
close this meeting at 12 31.